to the party shadow leader the house of
commons fangum debonair thank you very
much for being with us uh in the studio
uh this evening i thought was really
interesting actually i don't know if you
heard our panelists uh in talking about
kyocerma and this pledge to resign if he
is found
to have breached the law and to be given
a fine um
do you think that as our last um
panelists said that you know he has
really achieved anything by offering
this resignation
i think what he's achieved is drawn a
contrast between him
whereby he has already said he would
resign if he was issued with a fixed
penalty notice over this incident which
it just seems as one of your other
panelists said to be no comparison with
the prime minister where there is
partying on an industrial scale there is
just no comparison
10 downing street during the first
lockdown where there was wine brought in
in in suitcase loads and parties and
cakes and karaoke and guests there is no
comparison and i think it is a it's a
real mark of honor and it is the man i
know care to be um that he is offering
to do that right now but i'm also very
confident
i really trust in his judgment i also
know that the man's very good lawyer and
i'm pretty sure that uh that you know he
will have also thought long and hard
about what the best thing to do is for
the party for the country but i know
that his instincts are good and that he
works extremely hard and i'm looking
forward to seeing him being proved to
have not committed any breaches of rules
you say that he's a very good lawyer do
you think in that case he'll have looked
at the evidence and he'll be pretty
confident that it's going to go one way
otherwise no i i mean that actually that
he's missed the rules like all the way
through i mean this this is a man who's
like got the rules absolutely down i
mean he's he's had to isolate six times
because of covert tests in his own
family or acquaintances he's really
painstakingly stuck to the rules at some
personal cost to him in his family so
i'm saying that in in the sense that he
really understands the rules he really
understands the law he always does he's
very good at bay oil to explain what the
rules mean one thing that i am still a
bit unclear about is what happens if
durham police do exactly what they did
with dominic cummings they basically say
that they think
that the rules were broken but they
don't issue a fine does kirsten resign
then i mean i think if they think that
the rules have been broken then they
they will be issuing a fine but i don't
think the rules have been broken the
case because i think that durham police
have previously said that they don't
issue retrospective fines and they
obviously didn't with dominic cummings
wow so it feels like it's perhaps even
the most likely scenario
i mean you know they i want the police
to do their job i know the police will
be working hard to do a really thorough
and objective and fair job and when that
happens i mean kier has said that he's
very confident because he knows what
he's talking about he knows what
happened that that's not going to happen
but if it does then he would resign i'm
i'm not really going to get into whether
or not there's a difference of emphasis
there because i think that that gets in
the way of the police doing their job
okay we've been talking a lot about
northern ireland on the programme today
as well uh jeffrey donaldson the dep
leader effectively saying that they're
not going to enter this power sharing
arrangement until the northern ireland
protocol is scrapped yeah what do you
make of the dep position well
that's their position i think the key
person here though is boris johnson
because the northern ireland protocol
was his thing he went to negotiate it he
was the one who came out waving it
around saying he got a deal he needs to
own it and he also needs to make it work
i'm not saying it's perfect i think
there are things they need to sort out
but this is not statecraft on boris
johnson's part so i think it's left all
parties feeling like they're fed up
frustrated whatever side they're on they
need that sort of leadership to come
from the prime minister we're not seeing
it at the moment i'd really like him to
do that because the last thing we need
in the cost of living crisis sophie is a
trade war with our nearest trading
partners and that's what we're risking
um so you you would like to see
leadership from the prime minister in
what direction what do you want him to
do because they've you know they've
hinted to say that they will
unilaterally get rid of parts of the
brexit deal without the eu agreement if
necessary well i think that's deeply
unhelpful because that's basically
threatening a trade war and we really
can't afford to do that at a time of
stagnant growth
and crippling price rises we really need
boris johnson to show more leadership
than that there are things that he could
do now which could help shift the
negotiations if he went back to the eu
and said let's start with negotiating on
vet regulations which would help deal
with some of the border crossing issues
for food and animal products that would
be a start and it would be a way of
getting people back around the table and
saying look we got to be able to find
some common ground here so whatever
happens you don't think that the uk
should do anything without eu agreement
because effectively that would break
international law is that where you're
coming i mean i think
agreements that you know the clues in
the world it actually was boris
johnson's agreement in the first place
now if he can't make this one work he
needs to find a way to make it and make
it amended so that it does work the last
thing we need is no agreement because
that doesn't benefit us it doesn't
benefit british workers doesn't benefit
british businesses it would be a real um
damaging effect on our economy so it's
not good for us but the dep i guess
would argue that you know if
if if he's not going to do anything
without the eu approvement that's
damaging for northern ireland because
they're having to by the brunt of these
checks but that's what negotiations for
isn't it and that's what statesman uh
the statesmanlike behavior that we ought
to be able to expect from our prime
minister that's what we ought to be
seeing at this time okay thank you very
much for being on the programme thanks
very much fangum debonair there from
labour